we have time for one question uh-oh
is there a god
um uh you asked me this on your pocket i
know yeah remind me i said um that i
think there is a god yeah i don't think
he necessarily has a beard or is white
yeah you know or a shaved latina i know
yeah
i don't necessarily think he looks like
caviar bardem
i think there's definitely a higher
power okay something that's i would hope
there's something bigger than us i mean
right well if we're all the best there
is that's pretty sad for the world you
know i feel like that's what the
cordless phones at best buy are saying
it's got to be more than this right
there are other aisles it can't just be
home phones
tell me there's a fax machine or
something your mind is is his mind is
horrifying
it's like a it's like a yard sale of
just madness i mean i just is it scary
in there or is it like a playground it's
hard to sleep
i mean i can you imagine you're just so
goddamn talented i want to hang out with
you all the time because you're so funny
no on camera
let's keep it let's keep it professional
we've never spoken
on a non-recorded i don't have your
number
i texted you today if you did i couldn't
get on the lot how the mighty have
fallen
i could not get into the show today i
was waiting out there forever i had the
worst moment and i went in and i was
like just tell them it's when you're
coming you're like oh and i like rolled
down the window and i was like
hi guys and they were like do you have
an id or something i was like oh god
damn it
oh no so then i blew him
we both know that's not true we both
know that's not true thank you
i don't want to rap i know you have to
i've had to talk to her this is the
worst part about it i know but i don't
want it to be right now you have to wrap
it up because i've got to get out of
here i'm bored
i'm not bored you know that's not true i
know we're having a fun time with
friends being funny
he's by the way you guys love him the
audience loves him so much that's so
exciting you're a superstar and i hope
um you do this forever i really
appreciate that and i i sincerely hope
you come back as often as you i would
love to
come
whitney cummings everybody my erotic
friend
whitney cummings we'll be right back
with more show
holy smokes